more stars come to ellen's defense as
she faces accusations of a
toxic work environment but here's the
big question is ellen
on her way out i'll walk away really
when i
when i stop having fun i hope i know
when when people kind of are tired of me
i think i'll sense that people get tired
of people and especially in
today's age a source tells e.t that
ellen quote
has been really tuned out in the past
few years noting possible fatigue from
doing the show for 17 years now we're
told
sure sometimes people walk on eggshells
around her
but she's the boss and hollywood is
choosing sides
this is one of my gifts for you is that
he's here today
ashton kutcher tweeted that ellen had
always treated him with kindness
kevin hart defended his support of ellen
i'm a friend
as a friend if i have a friend in
trouble ever i'm gonna do my best to try
to be there for that
i'm not gonna let instagram comments and
twitter comments
tell me who can and can't be my friends
you know i uh i um
i love portia and ellen a source tells
e.t
ellen is great to celebrities but in the
time i've spent there
the staff was definitely running around
in fear there's a very negative and
fearful vibe
from the staff and yesterday tony
okamboa
who was the original dj on the ellen
degeneres show says
he experienced toxicity on the set
adding
that he stands with his fellow former
employees in their quest to create a
healthier and more inclusive workplace
we've seen some well-known people brad
garrett and leah thompson
say they believe all these stories about
alan
are are true sure i believe all victims
but i just wanted ellen
and porsha to know that i love them very
much
and obviously something has to change in
that work environment
but i do love porsha and ellen i do
as for ratings well they just hit an
all-time low
granted ellen's show is in reruns but
after reports that the show's work
culture was toxic
ratings were down 29 from the same week
last summer
ellen's show plans to start shooting new
episodes next month
and et has learned that a virtual staff
meeting was held on monday
to update them on the current
investigation into workplace misconduct
if the investigation reveals that ellen
somehow was a part of the
alleged harassment or creating a hostile
work environment
then that becomes problematic but if it
shows
that she really didn't know that she was
shielded from
all the things that were happening then
i think that gives
ellen some hope i definitely think
there's an opportunity for her to come
[Music]
back
you